Okay. Um, good morning. Today, uh, we
will do Genghis Khan and the Mongolian
conquest.
Now, um, as you know, the Mongols have a
terrible reputation
for their brutality,
uh,
for, uh, their atrocities.
Um,
today, I want to make the argument to
you
that
what they did,
um, given the circumstances,
given, uh,
the constraints they were under, was
actually logical and understandable.
Okay?
So, that's the argument I will make to
you, uh, today.
All right. So, the Mongols. Uh, the
Mongols, um, as you know, they are a
steppe people.
Uh,
the steppe, um, are divided into the
western steppes and the eastern steppes.
Um, and they tra- they basically go from
Hungary in Europe all the way
to, uh, what is modern-day Mongolia.
And, um, as we discussed, steppe culture
is very different from agricultural
culture that we find in, um, in the
Levant, in Anatolia, in Meso-
Mesopotamia, and in China.
In the grasslands, the economy is what
we call nomadic pastoral, meaning they
will raise cattle as their source of
food, and they will, uh, travel wherever
there is grassland. Okay? So, they And
because of their economy, they have
developed a certain culture. They are
extremely, uh, violent.
Um, their society, their culture is
based around violence.
And, um, there's a lot of competition,
uh, within these student groups.
So,
um rather than think of these people as
as a
nation or race of people, it's better to
think of them as a culture.
Okay? And for the longest time
throughout human history, they have been
divided among many different uh tribes.
Throughout human history, the nomadic
pastoral people of the steppes have
always been in conflict with the
agricultural empires.
Um so, in response, the
agricultural empires, China and the
Persians, they have built walls and and
fortifications to counter their threat,
okay? So, as you can see, the Mongols
will eventually come south and invade
most of China.
Um and historically, the response has
been the Great Wall of of China. Okay?
Um but also in Central Asia, the steppe
people have been a threat as well, and
they have built uh fortified cities as a
as response.
Okay? So, even though
the steppe people
and the agricultural empires have always
been in conflict, the Mongols have had a
unique reputation in Western history as
the most brutal, as the most um
as the most violent, okay? So, the
question we're looking at today is why
were the Mongols unique in their
brutality?
Okay? So,
um
um there are lots of
things that were said about the Mongols
that we now know today were are not
true. Okay? So, for example, back in the
day,
um they had a reputation for
cannibalism.
Um they ate their
opponents. They ate their enemies. And
we know that's not true today. They also
had a reputation
for being devious. So, for example, um,
when they approach an enemy, they would
hold the cross. Okay, the cross is is a
symbol of Christianity. So, their
Christian enemies would see this and
think that they are allies.
Okay? And only when they discovered
that these are actually Mongols, um,
but by then it was much too late. Okay?
So, the Mongols had a reputation for
being extremely, uh, devious.
Um, they had a reputation for wanton
brutality. They would destroy entire
cities and kill all the people.
Um,
um, previously historians believed they
killed about 65 million people.
Um, to today that figure is disputed,
okay? But But if that is But if that was
the case, then the Mongols killed more
people than any other regime in,
uh, human history before the 20th
century.
Um, Mon- Genghis Khan is considered the
greatest conqueror in human history. So,
uh, that's the the statistic that
surprised everyone is one out of 200
males today, um,
they're a direct descendant of Genghis
Khan.
So, that's that's like 16 million
people, okay? 16 million males in the
world are direct descendants of, um,
Genghis Khan.
All right? So, that is the reputation
that the Mongols had for most of
history. And what I want to show you
today is the Mongols are not unique
among the steppe people, okay? And the
way they behaved, uh,
there was a,
um, strategy. There's a logic to the way
they behaved given the circumstances and
constraints they found themselves um,
under. Okay.
So,
as you know in this class
the step people were the greatest
conquerors in human history.
Okay? So, let's start it with the
Yamnaya who
were based in the Ukraine area. And we
know the Yamnaya who who are also
referred to as the Proto-Indo-Europeans
as well as the Aryans. Okay? They spread
throughout most of the western world.
So, they went to Europe and as we as you
know, they basically replaced the entire
male population of Europe.
And they intermarry with the local women
to create
European culture. They also went south
and conquered
Iran and India.
And then they went over to the
eastern steps as well. So, what's really
important for us to remember and I I I
know this is hard but the Mongol people
they are culturally
more similar to the
Yamnaya than they are to the Chinese.
Even though genetically
the Mongols may be more similar to the
Chinese, okay? In this class we focus on
cultural values rather than genetic
affinity.
Okay. So, over time what will happen to
the western steps is it will slowly
acclimatize itself to the surrounding
agricultural
empires. And slowly the western steps
will become integrated into the
the agricultural and into the
agricultural neighbors. So, the example
here is Scythia. Okay? So, Scythia is
slowly
it's it's an empire it's a step empire,
but slowly it's about to integrate
itself into what is modern-day Eurasia.
Okay?
Um from from the Scythians, you will you
will have a rise something called the
Median Empire, which will then give way
to the Persian Empire.
Over in the eastern steps, okay, the um
the step people come to conflict with
the Han Dynasty. And the Han Dynasty, as
we know from last class, is really the
last ethnically Chinese dynasty, and
they are intent
on
um a policy of eradication against the
step people. So, they come to conflict
with the step people who are now called
the Xiongnu, okay?
And what this conflict will do is drive
these people west.
Okay?
And this is interesting for us because
when they go west, they will splinter
off into different groups. When they go
all the way to Europe, they will be
known as the Huns. Okay, you may know
Attila the Hun. Well, Attila the Hun is
what was the leader of these people. The
Huns will drive
um the the western step people, meaning
the Goths, into the Roman Empire,
causing conflict with the Roman Empire,
okay? And the Goths will become the
foundation of modern-day Europeans.
Um
Okay.
So, this is the Han Empire at its peak
when it's in conflict with the uh Roman
Empire.
Um the step people, the Huns, will also
give rise to
um a people called the Göktürk Empire,
okay? And And they will sweep down, and
they will become the Seljuk Turks, uh
which will um take over Mesopotamia.
And then eventually you will have uh
emerge the Ottoman Empire from these
people.
Right?
So, in other words, the Mongols are just
um the most successful iteration of the
step people and their conflicts with the
agricultural empires.
So, the Mongol Empire is the second
largest empire ever in human history.
Only the British Empire
um had more land. The Mongols were the
largest contiguous
empire, meaning meaning it was all it
was all interconnected together.
All right?
Um
at its height, the Mongol Empire
extended from basically what is
modern-day Russia all the way to China,
okay? The
um the empire that will take over the
Mongols centuries later is the Russian
Empire, okay? The Russian Empire will
take over a lot of Mongol
uh territory.
Um because it is so large,
um after the death of Genghis Khan and
uh his son uh
Ogadai, the
Mongol Empire will splinter into
four major
um
empires, okay? And these four major
major empires themselves will assimilate
and integrate into the local culture.
Um the Golden Horde will will eventually
give rise to
um the Russian Empire.
Um
the
Yuan Dynasty will eventually fall and
give rise to the Ming Empire, okay? So,
even though they conquer a lot of
territory, um ultimately their empire is
not sustainable. And later on, I will
explain to you why it was not
sustainable and why ultimately the
Mongol Empire declined.
But while it was still
in place, it created something called
the Pax Mongolica. Okay, this is Latin
for the Mongol peace.
You've heard of the Pax Romana. We are
now living in the Pax Americana. Okay,
so the Mongols created something called
the Pax
Mongolica, which just meant they
believed in globalization. They wanted
their conquered nations to trade with
each other because they could collect
they could collect taxes on the trade
and they encouraged people, especially
merchants, to
travel across their empire and trade
with each other. And during this time, a
very famous
Italian named Marco Polo had a chance to
visit the world and his travels,
especially
those to China, captured the imagination
of Europeans. This is really the first
time that China figured into the
European imagination. Okay. So this is a
map of
Marco Polo's travels.
Okay, and as you can see, he basically
traveled all across the
Pax
Mongolica. Okay.
The problem though is that when you
integrate the world like this, you also
give rise to disease. So the Black Death
traveled
all across the world. Okay, so we
believe the Black Death originated in
Central Asia in a in a place we we call
Kazakhstan today and it traveled all
over
the Mongol Empire. It made its way to
Europe and it devastated Europe. Okay,
it killed
anywhere between a third to half of the
entire population of Europe.
It traveled also to uh former Islamic
Empire and it traveled to China, but it
was not as devastating. Okay? It's very
important for us to understand. The
Black Death was devastating devastating
for Europe, but it was not that
devastating for China
and the Islamic Empire. And the reason
why is sanitation and hygiene.
So, in China and in in former Islamic
Empire, uh their cities were pretty well
organized, pretty wealthy, pretty
civilized. But, in Europe, um their
streets were literally filled with
manure, okay? They had horses. They
didn't have sanitation. People just
threw
um
onto the streets. And so, like when
you walk the streets, they were
literally covered with And in that
sort of environment, uh diseases spread
very rapidly.
But, the Black Death is important for us
also because it will give rise to the
Renaissance, which we'll do next week,
okay? So, without the Black Death,
historians believe the Renaissance could
not have happened. Uh the Black Death
basically meant a reset of European
society, and it allowed uh massive
innovation in Europe.
Okay? So, as you can see, the Black
Death was extremely devastating for
Europe.
Um
after the Mongols will come another
great conqueror called Timur the Lame,
Tamerlane. And he will be the last great
conqueror from the steppes. After
After Tamerlane, the agricultural
empires will develop the technology to
repel the steppe invaders, mainly
gunpowder, okay?
Um the technology
and mass armies will overwhelm the
steppe people, and eventually,
um over time, the agricultural nations,
mainly Russia, will start to colonize
and conquer the steppes.
Right?
Okay. So, look at Let's look at today at
Genghis Khan, who is the founder of the
Mongol Empire. Okay?
Um
Mong- Genghis Khan will you first of all
unite the warring tribes of the Mongol
people. He'll turn them into a
confederation, and then the
confederation will aim to conquer China,
but then it will come into conflict with
the Central Asian nations. And so, um
Genghis Khan will embark on the Central
Asian campaigns that are brutal. He'll
wipe out entire cities. He'll He'll kill
all the He'll kill all in- in-
inhabitants. And he will lay the
foundation
for the Mongol conquest
uh that will follow after him.
Okay? And again, um after the death of
his son, Ögedei, the Mongols will split
into four major factions, and they will
attempt to continue the legacy of
conquest. But, what happened is after
the conquer of the Song Empire in in
1279, they will attempt to conquer
uh Japan and Vietnam.
And when they try to do so, they will be
repelled. They try to conquer Japan
twice,
um and even though the legend is that
Japan was saved by the Kamikaze, right?
The great divine wind. Um I will show
you that's actually not true.
Um there's another reason why the
Mongols stopped invading uh Japan. So,
in the east, they're they've reached the
limit of their conquest. Um they tried
to conquer India as well, but when they
tried to do so, they were repelled. And
historians argue about the reason why
this is why this is the case. Some
believe it was because of the climate of
India. Some believe it was because of
some because the uh sultan of Delhi um
had a organized and concerted response.
Some other believe it was just internal
fighting, okay?
When they try to reach Europe, they will
um try to conquer Poland and Hungary,
and even though they win every single
battle against the Poles and Hungarians,
they will ultimately turn back. And and
that and that will be the limit of their
conquest in the West. So, the
um Mongolian fighting style is great
when you fight in flat plains, okay?
These are horsemen with bows, okay? So,
um they're fast, they can cover great
great distances.
But, when when they try to reach Europe,
and Europe is thick forest, right? They
really can't conquer that terrain.
One really stunning event is when they
try to conquer Egypt. Remember, Egypt
for the longest time was the wealthiest
part of the Western world. When when
they try to conquer Egypt, they run into
a people called the Mamluks, who fight
very similarly to the
uh Mongols. In fact, the the Mam- the
Mamluks are originally from the steppes,
as well. And for the first time,
uh the Mongols will be defeated
militarily on the battlefield.
And this sort of destroys the aura of
inevitability and invincibility that the
Mongols had for the longest time, okay?
And this will be the extent of their um
conquest in the West.
And after these conquests, the Mongol
Empire will try to rule their
respective um
empires, but ultimately they will fail,
okay? And later on, I'll explain to you
why they were doomed to fail.
And the irony is the reasons that gave
rise to the empire also reasons why they
their empire ultimately collapsed.
Okay?
Okay. So, I want to first talk about
Genghis Khan. And
so, we don't know much about Genghis
Khan. What we do know comes from a book
called The Secret History of the
Mongols. So, it is a um
oral history of the life and times of
Genghis Khan and his son, Ogedei.
Right? Now,
um the story in The Secret History
is suspicious. And it's suspicious
because it fits very well into the
structure of Proto-Indo-European
myth, all right? So, so let me show you
how it's similar.
Okay. In The Secret History, Genghis
Khan
um his mother um and and you know,
again, they are in the Mongolian
grasslands. His mother is about to be
wed to her husband. So, she's in her
carriage and she's along her along the
way to her husband's tribe. But along
along the way, she is ambushed and
kidnapped. That's a very common thing in
that culture. The way that you obtain a
wife is by stealing someone else's wife.
Uh and so, she she's forced to marry a
stranger.
Um but the stranger, Genghis Khan's
eventual father, dies when Genghis Khan
is 8 years old.
When the father dies, the tribe abandons
the mother and her young children. So,
they're forced to uh fend for
themselves.
Um
eventually
uh the mother finds a way to find a
supporting tribe and gets Genghis Khan
slowly finds mentors for protection.
Um
he eventually finds a mentor who becomes
his best friend. And this friend's best
friend's name is Jamukha, okay? And the
And the two together
um, are great warriors and they conquer
a lot of territory territory together.
In fact, when Genghis Khan's wife is
stolen by a tribe, the two will race off
and get the wife back. Um, but by this
time, uh, Genghis Khan's wife is
pregnant with another man's
son.
Genghis Khan
raised the son as his own and he made
the son heir to his empire, which will
cause great difficulties, uh, when
Genghis Khan dies, okay? But that just
shows you the generosity, um, of this
man.
Eventually, Genghis Khan will run into
conflict with Jamukha. And the two are
competing for control of the Mongol
world. Genghis Khan kills him to, um,
achieve his dominance.
And, um,
um, Genghis Khan will overthrow the
existing Mongolian social order.
Basically, all these top chieftains, all
these top shamans, he will kill in order
to unite the Mongol people and bring
about a new social order, okay? So,
that's the story that we we have from
the secret history.
And that's very similar, by the way, to
other,
uh, founding myths of other people.
Like, for example, let's look at Rome,
okay?
So, um, remember last semester we
discussed Virgil's Aeneid, okay? And
it's about the founder of Rome, uh, his
name is Aeneas. Aeneas is a prince of
Troy and he has to watch destruction of
Troy. He escapes the He escapes the
sacking of Troy, where everyone is
killed, but he gets lost at sea, okay?
Eventually, he, um, stumbles onto
Carthage, where he falls in love with
the queen there named Dido.
But the gods demand that he leave He
leaves Dido, the woman that he loves and
he's married, and he does. He betrays
Dido, who then kills herself. Then he
goes to Italy, where he has to fight a
war in order to establish the Trojan
people
on Italy and they will eventually give
rise to the Roman people. Okay, so it's
so it's a very similar structure to the
story of Genghis Khan.
Let's go to another story from Rome. So
the founder of Rome is named Romulus who
is a direct descendant of Aeneas.
Um so two so there's a king
called Numitor
and his brother
Amulius usurps the throne. And once
Amulius usurps the throne, he puts
Numitor's daughter
into a temple and makes her a virgin,
okay? But Mars the the war god Mars
visits her and impregnates her with
twins.
Numitor demands the twins be killed and
the twins are left alone by the
Tiber River, okay? And everyone thinks
that they will drown. But they are
miraculously saved and a she-wolf nurses
them and a shepherd adopts them.
Eventually they discover their true
heritage and they help their grandfather
Numitor
kill um
his brother Amulius and restore the
throne. Then the two go off to found
their
their own city which is Rome, okay? But
they're going to be one king so the two
fight and Romulus kills his twin brother
Remus.
All right?
And then Romulus becomes Rome's first
king which will eventually give rise to
the greatest empire in the European
world. All right, so as you can see the
structures are very similar. So let's go
over very quickly the structure and
meaning
of Proto-Indo-European
myth. The thing I want to remember is
that what mythology ultimately is, it's
a collective subconscious
of a culture.
Okay? By understanding mythology, we can
understand the fundamental values that
underpin this culture. So,
what is the structure we're looking at?
Okay.
The structure is this. First, the gods
favor a man with a divine mission. But
the man himself does not understand this
divine mission. Okay? The gods have
picked this man for whatever reason, and
this man must fulfill his divine
mission.
And in the process, he will suffer
hardship to become as hard as a sword,
okay? Hardship makes you committed. It
makes you strong.
And to recognize his mission, okay? In
the process, he's asking he's asking
himself, "Why am I being persecuted? Why
am I suffering so much?" And then
eventually, he will he will have an
epiphany. He will recognize, "Oh, it's
because the gods have a mission for me
that I must fulfill. That's why I'm
That's why I'm suffering. That's why I'm
being persecuted. It's to make me strong
and committed." Okay?
And he will sacrifice his beloved to
prove his commitment to his divine
mission, okay? This is really important.
In Proto-Indo-European myth, the hero
must always sacrifice his beloved. So,
remember the story of Genghis Khan, he
sacrifices uh he kills his best friend,
Jamukha, okay? And you think, "Okay,
what's the big deal?" Well, in that
culture,
when two warriors are best friends,
they're not just friends, okay? They're
basically lovers.
They have sex with each other, and
that's why uh they're such great
warriors together.
It's a very common thing. So, remember
the Iliad, where
um in the Iliad, Hector kills Patroclus,
and Achilles
um
becomes so enraged that he goes and
kills Hector, okay?
So, um
why did Achilles become so enraged?
Because Patroclus was his best friend,
which at that time every everyone
understood to mean Patroclus and
Achilles were lovers.
Okay? Achilles loved Patroclus.
So, when Genghis Khan killed Jamukha, he
was basically killing the man he loved
the most in this world.
Okay? That's a very important part of
Proto-Indo-European myth. You have to
show your commitment by making the
ultimate sacrifice, which means killing
the person you love the most.
And once he does that, he will shatter
the old world to build a new one, okay?
That is the divine mission. The gods do
not like this world. They want a flood
to destroy this world in order for the
world to be made anew. And this man, the
Messiah, he is the one who will shatter
the old world. He's the world shatterer,
okay? He's the flood sent by the gods.
All right? So, that's the basic
structure of Proto-Indo-European myth.
And we And And when we understand this,
now what we can do is understand the
power
of the Jesus story within Christianity.
Why is Christianity the most uh
influential and popular religion in the
world? It has to do with the story of
Jesus, okay?
In the story of Jesus,
according to the Gospel of Mark,
let's look at the structure, okay? It's
very similar to Proto-Indo-European
mythology. Jesus has a secret divine
mission, okay? He's sent by God or he is
God um
come who's come to redeem the world.
He must suffer persecution and doubt,
okay? So, everyone doubts who he is. No
one knows who he is. He's laughed at.
He's mocked, okay?
He then is sacrificed to wake the world.
He kills himself. Or he is sacrificed so
that everyone knows
how much God loves them.
And with God's sacrifice, the cycle of
violence ends and a new history begins,
okay? So, in Proto-Indo-European myth,
what's important is that you kill your
beloved.
But, the founding myth of Christianity
is, "No, I kill myself to show you that
violence is terrible."
Okay? Once God has killed himself, once
God has sacrificed himself, it means
that all violence now must cease. The
cycle of violence, the cycle of using
violence to redeem the world, to cleanse
the world, must come to an end.
Okay? And that's the very idea,
foundational idea of Christianity. And
so, what Christianity is doing, that's
very clever, is it's taking the
collective subconscious that's embedded
in every individual and implanting a new
idea within the subconscious that grows
and grows.
Okay? It's almost like a virus until
people recognize that violence is bad.
Proto-Indo-European mythology celebrates
violence, right? Christianity
uh believes violence is the worst thing.
Okay? So, so
So, let's um
sorry, um this is a bit uh okay. All
right, anyway, I'll I'll I'll just read
it to you, okay?
So, this is the ending of Mark, okay?
Then Jesus gave a loud cry and breathed
his last, okay? So, he's been
sacrificed. He's died.
And the curtain of the temple was torn
in two from top to bottom. The temple is
the temple second temple in Jerusalem,
where Yahweh is. And at the very top of
this temple is a room called the holy of
the holies. That's where God lives.
And the curtain is what um
hides
uh God from the world, okay? So, when
Jesus died, the curtain now is torn in
half, meaning God is now released into
the world, which means that which means
that everyone now has access to God.
God is now on Earth.
Okay?
Now, when the Centurion, this the
soldier who stood facing him saw that in
this way, he breathed his last, he said,
"Truly, this man was God's son." So, the
first person
that Jesus revealed himself to
was a Roman soldier. The first person
that recognized
the truth of Jesus
and the power of his sacrifice was the
Roman soldier who's always been taught
that violence is the answer to
everything. And once he's converted, he
he he recognizes that violence is wrong
and evil. Okay? So, that's the power of
um
this mythology. Okay? Does that make
sense to you guys?
All right.
So, now I want to look at
real history, okay? Because this is
mythology. And what I want to do now is
show you that Genghis Khan fits into the
a pattern of a great conqueror.
If you look at all the great conquerors
of human history, and I'll list four
right now, okay? Sargon of Akkad, Philip
of Macedon, Julius Caesar, and Genghis
Khan, you will see they are very, very
similar.
Okay? So, let's look at Sargon of Akkad.
Remember um before
in Meso- in Mesopotamia, it was divided
into the Sumerian city-states that
warred with each other. And these these
were walled cities. Because these were
walled cities, they couldn't really
conquer each other, okay? Sargon of
Akkad figured out a way to conquer
everyone and build the first empire in
world history called the Akkadian
Empire.
So, we don't know much about him, but
this is what we know.
First of all, he was probably a
mercenary, okay? It was very common back
then
um to be a mercenary because these
city-states were at war with with each
other always.
He was a cupbearer to the king Ur-Zababa
of Kish. Kish is one of these
city-states in Sumeria. Now, guys,
cupbearer is a very important position.
A cupbearer means that when you're at
the king and you have a feast and a or a
festival for your people, the cupbearer
is a man who stands beside you and pours
you the alcohol, the wine, right?
Which means this is a man you trust the
most.
So, what does it mean for Sargon Akkad
to be a cupbearer? Well, it probably
means that they were lovers. The king
and Sargon were lovers who loved each
other deeply, okay?
But, that doesn't prevent Sargon from
killing the king and taking the throne,
which starts this massive war in the
city states in which
um Sargon will eventually triumph, okay?
Um
well, so the thing about Sargon is he is
really good at
um winning the favor of mentors, right?
And ultimately he'll betray mentors in
order to achieve his ambition.
Well, that's also true for Philip of
Macedon. So, um Philip of Macedon, he is
a prince of Macedon.
And at this time in the Greek world,
Thebes was the dominant military power.
Thebes defeated Macedon in a battle and
Thebes demanded hostages. So, Philip was
sent as a hostage to Thebes where he is
now mentored
by the greatest military strategist of
this time named Epam- my- nondas, okay?
And so, Philip the second is learning
how to win battles. He's learning all
the major military innovations of this
time from the greatest general of this
time. And then what he will do is he
will return to Macedon, reorganize the
Macedonian army, and then take them to
conquer Thebes as well as the entire uh
Greek world at the Battle of Chaeronea,
okay?
Well, this pattern is also true for
Julius Caesar.
In this at this time
which is about like 50
uh BCE in Rome, Pompey the Great is the
greatest general. He's the man that
everyone admires. He has most political
power. So, what Julius Caesar does is
he's he marries his daughter to Pompey
the Great and this forms a political
alliance between the two.
Pompey the Great grants him
um generalship of the province of Gaul
where Julius Caesar will win military
glory, okay? It basically establishes
the power, prestige, and fame of Julius
Caesar.
And this will start a civil war in which
um Julius Caesar will defeat his mentor,
Pompey, at the Battle of Pharsalus.
Okay? Very similar pattern.
Well, the same is also true for Genghis
Khan. He is mentored by two chieftains,
Jamukha and Toghrul, and he will defeat
both in order to gain leadership of the
Mongol world. So, it shows you how
ruthless
and ambitious these great conquerors
are. But, at the same time, let's
remember this.
Philip II had a really talented
subordinate in Parmenion. Parmenion was
really uh the person in charge of the
Macedonian army. In fact, it was
Parmenion who was mostly responsible for
Alexander the Great's conquest of
Persia, okay?
Uh Julius the Julius Caesar had a
talented subordinate in Titus Labienus,
who was responsible for his victories in
Gaul. And then Genghis Khan had a
talented subordinate in Subutai, who was
considered one of the greatest military
strategists
um ever.
Okay?
And so, what this tells us is
they're able to have
they're able to exercise tremendous
judgment in people. They know who to
trust.
They know who not to trust. They know
who is talented and who is not talented.
They know how to how to win the loyalty
of their subordinates. Okay? That's a
very impressive skill.
And then the question then is, how is it
possible that they are ruthlessly
ambitious, yet at the same time they're
able to delegate power in a very
effective manner? And the answer is,
they all believe they have a divine
mission.
Their goal is not to conquer the world.
Their goal is to change the world for
the better as demanded by the gods.
Does that make sense?
That's the only way we we can understand
this. Each in their own way believe they
are the Messiah sent by the gods
to shatter the world so that so that it
can be built anew.
Okay?
And that's what drives them to kill
their beloved.
And that's what drives them to
um
um do what they do, okay?
Um all four, ultimately they are able to
conquer the world because they develop a
professional, meritocratic, and
innovative army, okay? What does
professional mean? It means that
look at Sargon the Great, uh Sargon of
Akkad.
At this time, there were no professional
soldiers.
Um most people were farmers, and you
only fought off-season, okay? You might
fight two, three months of the year.
Sargon of Akkad um was the first to say,
"Nope, we will have professional
soldiers. Everyone else will pay taxes
in order for me to uh pay my
professional army, but these are
professional soldiers. They are
full-time
um
soldiers at war, okay?" Uh meritocratic
means the system uh before was the
nobility always had
a priority. The nobility was always
right.
And Akkad Sargon of Akkad made the
system more open
and fair and meritocratic. So, if you
were talented and you were brave, you
could rise within the ranks of the army
regardless of your heritage and your
background. Innovative means they were
always adapting and learning. So, Sargon
of Akkad was able to conquer the
Sumerian city-states, which again were
walled, by adopting siege warfare, which
was unheard of before. Okay?
And the same is true for Philip, Julius
Caesar, and Genghis Khan. Right? So,
again, Genghis Khan fits into a pattern
here of what these great conquerors look
like.
Does this make sense to you guys?
Any questions?
So far?
All right. Let's continue.
Okay. So, um now I want to discuss
why the Mongols did what they did.
Okay?
Why did the Mongols commit so many
atrocities?
What was the logic or reasoning
behind their brutality?
Right?
All right.
In order for me for me to do so, I'm
going to introduce you to you today a
new analytical model called game theory.
Okay? The idea of game theory is this.
All human reaction
can be perceived as a game
in which two people, at least two people
are playing and they're trying to to
defeat each other. Okay?
So, for example, let's just say,
you know,
um
these two guys
are
um fighting each other, okay? They want
to kill each other.
Now, according to game theory,
each person has a distinctive optimal
strategy, okay? It's called optimal
strategy.
Optimal strategy is
given the constraints of your
circumstance,
what is the best way for you to win?
Okay, so if you're the big guy, okay?
This is the big guy, he wants the game
to be fair, which is like, let's just
arrange to fight at a certain time, and
we'll fight, okay? And he And he will he
wants to uh use this strategy because he
is most likely to win.
But if you're this guy, a small guy,
right? Let's call him A, and you're
fighting B, you don't want to do that
because you're bound to lose. So, what
you do is you figure out a time when uh
B is most vulnerable, maybe when he when
he's asleep or he's eating, and you
attack him then, okay? You basically
have to cheat in order to win. So, each
individual has a distinctive optimal
strategy, all right? Now, this sounds
easy, but it's not because often there
are multiple players in the game, okay?
So, you have C,
and you have D.
And when when you have multiple players
in the game, you have to think about
about alliances and coordination, okay?
So, it's possible that A and D will form
alliance to attack B, which will force B
and C to form alliance, okay? But once
maybe
uh C and B kill off D, then
A and C will form alliance to kill off
B, okay?
So, what this tells us is not only does
each person have an optimal strategy
given the constraints
um
of the game, but this optimal strategy
will change according to the
circumstances.
All right? Also, what's important for us
to remember is that there are there are
there always these external
um constraints. And ex- external
constraints might be just weather or
weapons or whatever, okay? So, game
theory sounds easy, but it's extremely
complicated because you always have to
switch perspective
in order to better understand why this
person is doing what he or she is doing.
Okay? Does that make sense?
All right. So,
let's look at um game theory and apply
it to the Mongols. Okay, remember the
Mongols are a borderland people and
they're fighting empires. And remember
with you if you're a borderland, okay,
borderland
empire
you have three distinct advantages.
Okay, you have energy.
Um you're open
and you're opportunistic.
Okay, these are the three advantages
that you have as a borderland people
like the Mongols. As an empire, your
three advantages are mass. You have a
lot of people. You have organization.
You have depth.
Okay?
So,
um
it seems
so So, again, given the strengths, it is
not that
um
easy to determine who will win. Okay,
but we're trying to figure out the
mentality of the Mongols, okay? We know
the Mongols have these three strengths
and they're trying to defeat the empire,
which has these three strengths. At the
same time, we have to remember the
Mongols themselves have three
fundamental weaknesses that they must
compensate for if they are to win, okay?
So, let's go over their major
constraints. The first constraint that
they have is extremely low population.
Okay, there are not that many of them.
In fact, they're often outnumbered often
100 to 1.
And so, that's a major constraint.
Um at when when Genghis Khan was alive,
at his height, he had anywhere between
100,000 100,000 to 200,000
troops, okay?
The second constraint is
the idea of distance and geography. What
I mean by that is
the Mongols
had to fight over huge territory because
Central Asia Asia is a huge
land, right? And this is problematic
because of supply issues.
Supplies.
What this means is if you are the
Mongols, the thing that you cannot ever
fight is a war of attrition.
A war of attrition just means
a long war in which in which you're
trying to deplete the other person's
resources. If you are the If you are the
Mongols, the worst thing that can ever
happen to you is if you're stuck in a
war of attrition.
If the siege is too long or the war
lasts for too long, okay? Because
eventually you'll run out soldiers.
So, that's what the Mongols fear the
most, okay? So, distance. The last
thing, this is really important, is
governance.
Governance just means the Mongols are
nomadic people who do not know how to
govern other people. So, they don't want
to be stuck in a situation where they're
forced to govern other people.
Okay?
Does that make sense?
And what this means is the idea of whole
territory.
When you conquer a new land, what you
usually do is you put in place a new
regime. They can't do that because they
don't have the personnel for that.
Okay? They often don't even have the
personnel for siege warfare, but what
they will do is recruit Chinese
engineers,
um Indian engineers in in order to
implement siege warfare, okay? But
bureaucrats are very hard to
um compensate for, okay? So, these are
the three fundamental weaknesses of the
Mongol system. Low population, they have
to fight uh long distances, and
therefore they have they have to worry
about supplies, and they don't know how
to govern other people, okay? And if if
we do this, okay? If we look at what the
strengths are and we look at what their
fundamental constraints are, then
we can figure out what their ultimate
strategy is, okay?
So, this is the ultimate strategy for
the Mongols.
The first is escalation dominance.
Okay, escalation dominance is this.
Okay, there's there's a concept
in political science called escalation
ladder.
The escalation ladder I mean it's a very
simple concept. It means like
violence
always escalates. So, for example,
I get into an argument with someone,
okay? Well, what first happens is we
start to argue,
but then eventually this argument
becomes more much more heated and we
start to push each other, okay? Then I
then I might throw a punch, he throws a
punch back, then I might bite him, he
might bite me back,
I might pull out a knife, he might pull
out a gun, okay? This is called
escalation
ladder, okay? Violence has to happen
over time, okay?
And this is fine if this is fine, but
the problem is what if you're fighting
multiple people at once, right?
So, what you want to do is show other
people that you are more dominant, okay?
So, if you insult me, I'll put a gun on
you, now shoot you, okay? That's the
idea of escalation dominance. I always
have the capacity
to inflict more damage on you than you
could ever possibly inflict on me.
Okay? And that's why
the Mongols
did what they did. So,
what what will often happen is the
Mongols would send
a trade delegation to a nation to
negotiate a trade deal. And the nation,
um, prob- usually in Central Asia,
um, they would kill all the delegation
in order to insult Genghis Khan. In
response, Genghis Khan would send his
army to destroy the entire city, burn
down the city, and kill everyone, okay?
This is the idea of escalation
dominance. You have to prove escalation
dominance if you are to, um,
to be a viable threat to everyone, okay?
So, that's the first idea.
Escalation dominance. Second idea is the
idea of terror.
Or what we call psychological warfare.
If you are badly outnumbered in warfare,
then you have to have you have to make
people afraid to fight you, okay? If you
cannot govern people, if you don't know
how to properly manage people, you have
to make people afraid to rebel, okay?
So, the Mongols were notorious for
psychological warfare. So, for example,
what they would do is this. They would
conquer some territory, and to ensure
the villagers would not ever rebel, they
would send one
Mongol soldier into the village, okay?
And this is one soldier, and there might
be a thousand villagers. And then what
this Mongol soldier will do is randomly
kill some villagers. He'll say, "Hey,
you guys come over here, line up." And
he starts killing people randomly, okay?
And if the villagers ever rebel,
and kill him, then the Mongols will come
and kill everyone in the village.
All right? So, that's the idea of
psychological psychological warfare.
But the Mongols do this do this to
do this to themselves as well, okay? So,
the Mongols have a system where units
are divided into units of 10, okay? So,
10 soldiers,
um, and then these 10 soldiers times 10
will make up a unit. So, what would
happen is this.
If ever in a battle
um
one soldier
ran away from battle
all of the people in these units would
be
um executed. Okay? But if if one unit
ever ran away, then the next unit 100 of
them would all be executed. Okay? So,
this gives everyone incentive to make
sure
your fellow soldier does not run away.
Okay? So, the Mongols had psychological
warfare not just for other people, but
also for themselves. And that's just the
way the Mongols fought.
And they had to fight like this given
the fact that they were greatly
outnumbered.
And they had to win quickly against
their
um enemies.
Right?
Does that make sense?
Okay? Now, the last thing, which is the
most important, is they had to create an
aura
of inability
and invincibility.
At this time, people were literally
telling people these Mongols are not
human. They are demons. They have come
from Tartarus. And And that's where
where where where where we get the name
Tartars. They have come from Tartarus,
hell, in order to kill everyone. Okay?
These are demons. Guess what, guys? The
Mongols wanted this reputation. Okay?
They did everything they could in order
to promote this reputation because it
gave them an aura of inability and
invincibility. They could not be
defeated.
There's no point in trying to defeat
them. So, let's just give up.
Okay? And most did.
Most said like the Mongols were able to
conquer so much territory so fast
because they had this aura of inability
and invincibility and most people just
gave up. They just paid tribute. And if
you didn't do so, then they would use
escalation dominance and terror to
um kill everyone.
Okay?
And they would send refugees all around
the world, so everyone would know about
the ferocity and brutality of the
Mongols.
Okay? Does that make sense, guys?
So, in other words, I have to say this,
but according to game theory,
everything the Mongols did made complete
uh sense, okay? In fact, it's their
optimal strategy, okay?
Given the circumstances, given the
constraints, what they did was
completely logical and reasonable, even
though it resulted in the deaths of 10
tens of millions of people.
Okay? Does that make sense?
All right.
Okay. So, then So, now let's discuss
why their empire collapsed.
All right. So,
there's a fundamental weakness in the
entire Mongol optimal strategy approach.
It's a great strategy if you are trying
to conquer the people.
But, when you're trying to govern them,
okay, it's an issue.
All right. So,
um as we discussed,
the Mongols are great warriors,
uh like all steppe people, because of
their cultural values. This is a
culture, okay, that emphasizes three
things.
First is freedom.
Second is egalitarianism, okay?
And the third is self-reliance.
Okay? So, rather than think of the
Mongol the army as a empire or
organization, it's more like a
confederation. People choose to join
this confederation because of the
immense rewards
that can be achieved through conquest,
okay?
Um so this is a culture that values
freedom, egalitarianism, and
self-reliance, and therefore it makes
great warriors.
The problem though is the cultures they
conquer were extremely
extreme hierarchies.
All right? Where you have maybe the
emperor at the top, a bureaucracy,
and then peasantry at the very bottom.
So the vast majority were
peasants, okay? Now, um I know this is
hard for us to understand, but the
reason why the Mongols were able to
conquer these empires
were
almost a contempt
for these empires. Does that make sense,
guys? The Mongols had absolutely no
respect for these empires. They thought
they were weak, they thought they were
corrupt, and um decadent, okay? So So
the Mongols were able to conquer them.
Okay? Does that make sense? There's a
contempt for them. The contempt is this.
The mong- underlying the ultimate
strategy
of the Mongols is a concept that never
existed in human history before. And the
concept is this.
People
are an infinite resource.
Okay?
So throughout most of human history,
people were the most valuable resource.
There was not many of people around.
Therefore, you have to treat people
nicely if you want to maximize their
productivity.
Okay?
But where were the Mongols based? They
were based in East Asia.
They were based in China, basically. And
in China, because of the empire, people
were treated like an infinite resource.
You could massacre them. You could send
them off in human wave attacks.
It didn't matter because they were an
infinite resource. And this idea never
existed before in human history. And in
the Western world, this concept is
radically revolutionary.
It was unimaginable like you could do
this.
So, remember
Julius Caesar, even though he
um
when he conquered Rome,
he wasn't intent on massacring people.
Why? Because people could be sold as
slaves. That was the main way he made
his fortune, by selling the Gauls as
slaves.
Okay?
But if you believe that people are an
infinite resource,
then you don't want them as slaves,
okay? You want you want to kill as many
people as possible in order to inflict
terror.
Okay? So, that that's the issue with the
Mongols. First of all,
their virus system did not lend itself
to um governing a hierarchy. They didn't
know how to and they didn't want to.
Also, much more problematic was their
contempt for the local culture.
Okay?
If you have contempt for local culture,
you're going to have problems managing
the people. So, in China during the Yuan
Dynasty, the Chinese
um there's a class system. The Mongols
were at the top and the uh Chinese were
at the very bottom, okay? The foreigners
were sort of in between.
And that just shows you the Mongol
contempt for for Chinese people. And
that's why ultimately uh the Chinese
people rebelled against the Mongols.
Right? Now, eventually, the Mongol
leadership would recognize
this
problem and they would try to adopt um a
Chinese-style bureaucracy. But a
bureaucracy, and we discussed this,
comes into conflict with the nobility.
Okay? Nobility. The nobility is intent
on
maintaining the Mongolian culture. They
did not want to assimilate.
But the emperor recognized you have to
assimilate if you are to have this
empire. And because they couldn't agree,
the nobility and the emperor couldn't
agree, ultimately it led to the collapse
of the Mongol empire. Okay?
All right.
So, that's the history of the Mongols.
Any comments?
Any questions?
I
I I I I know Doug is.
Can you speak speak speak I don't have
any questions yet, though.
But but but but do do do do you want do
you want to comment? Because I I I know
you studied the Mongols quite quite
quite quite in
detail. Well, I'm kind of scared that
this is on YouTube.
It Okay. All right. Yeah.
All right. So, yeah, it's fine.
Okay. Any questions, guys?
Like, I know this there's a lot to take
take in. So,
um
you know, ask questions.
Tell me what areas you are confused by.
Okay, I got
I got I got a question. Okay. So, so a
few lessons ago Yep. you talked about if
there was
a Viking, you know, university, you
would definitely want to go to that.
Yeah. Right? And because like in
in the Viking world, you know,
it's all about freedom and equality and
self-reliance, right? Yeah. So, the
Vikings might be running Harvard, but
um
the
the Mongol university might be might be
the Oxford one.
Yeah. Yeah. Got any uh
Any sympathies one way or the Yeah,
that's a great question, okay? That's a
great question. Vikings versus Mongols,
okay?
Um
Okay.
All right, so
um
the Vikings and the Mongols all come
from a proto-Indo-European culture. What
we know about culture is that it's very
fluid
and it will change over time and it will
adapt itself to the local cultures,
okay?
And so
the Vikings were in Europe.
And the Mongols are near China, okay?
And
um
I'd just say
like um I think
if I wanted to be a Viking or Mongol,
I'd prefer to be a Viking, okay?
And the reason why is the Vikings never
really
um adopted
a belief that people were an infinite
resource. They couldn't because Europe
was very poor.
Um and the Vikings, regardless
even though they were brutal, they still
had respect for their opponents. They
never developed a contempt for their
opponents. They're surrounded by the
Byzantines, the Muslims, and the
Europeans. And these were great
warriors. So the Vikings felt they had a
lot to learn from these cultures. And in
fact, ultimately the Vikings will
assimilate themselves into these
cultures in different environments,
okay? So
um
The Mongols are different though. The
Mongols are based in East Asia
and they did ultimately adopt a belief
that people are an infinite resource.
They had tremendous contempt for Chinese
culture, okay? And
um that changes you as a person. When
you believe that um people are an
infinite resource and you are
contemptuous of other cultures
it also in a way
um makes you contemptuous of yourself,
if that makes any sense.
Okay?
Um and so, ultimately, that's why the
Mongols were not able to
uh even though they had tremendous
wealth, they didn't really produce
um cultural monuments.
We don't have I like like the Vikings I
I I mean as I mentioned, the Vikings
were fundamental development of Western
civilization. The Mongols were not
fundamental development of any
civilization. I mean, they caused a lot
of havoc, and they were great
conquerors, but they didn't leave a a
rich cultural legacy.
So, and I I think I think it has to do
with the belief like
people are infinite resource, okay? Um
so, I would pre- much prefer to be a
Viking. I I would be much prefer to be
enslaved by Viking than than a than a
Mongol. Like like if if if I if I if I
were a slave, I would rather much rather
be a slave to a Viking than a Mongol.
Okay? If I were a slave to a Viking, the
Vikings would at least become my friend.
They'd be like, "Hey, tell me about your
culture. Are there any stories that you
can tell us?"
Okay? And if you were a great
storyteller, then they would make you
um they would treat you very very nicely
cuz cuz you're you're helping them learn
more about your culture, okay? The
Mongols had I've seen no interest in
other cultures.
They were interested in conquering and
exploiting other people. All right? I
could be wrong, all right? And and I'm
probably making these rationalizations,
but I believe with the Vikings there's a
genuine curiosity about the world that
comes from a genuine respect of other
cultures.
Whereas the Mongols were not curious
about the world, they were intent on
conquest and enslaving other people and
exploiting other people. Okay? They were
predators.
And again, um that could be my
prejudice, but but based on my readings
so far, that that would be my um
um belief. But, please change my mind.
No, sounds good. Sounds good. Okay.
All right. Thanks for the question.
Okay, great great question. Any other
questions?
You mentioned that
in the Mongol culture they don't have a
lot of people.
Right.
What What What What What Sorry. Sorry.
So, population, okay? So, the Mongol
population is loosely defined.
Okay? Do Do Do Do Do Do Do Do Do you
understand?
Uh it's it's hard to say who's Mongol
and who's not Mongol because that that
that entire area has a similar culture
and it's it's very hard to figure out
where the where the borders are, okay?
Like You mentioned that civilization of
the Mongol that they have low
population. Yeah. Then why would they
believe that
people are
infinite resource. Okay, great question,
okay, yeah. So, you're right. So, the
Mongols are
um a low population. So, why would they
believe that people are infinite
resource? The answer is because they are
always in contact with China, okay? So,
the Mongols were always in contact with
China. And as And as I mentioned,
they're all The interaction happens in
three ways, okay? The Mongols are
working as either mercenaries for
dynasties in China or they are trading,
okay?
Or they're raiding and pillaging, okay?
So, uh for centuries there's been
contact between China and the Mongols.
So, where did the Mongols learn
the idea that people are infinite
resource? Well, they learned it from
China, right? And And why Why Why did
they learn from China? Because Chinese
warfare was also predicated on the
belief that people were infinite
resource. Does that make sense? So, ba-
basically the entire um idea of warfare
in China is I organize this peasant
army, I throw throw them at my opponent,
okay? And if my entire army dies, guess
what? I'll just go and I'll raise
another peasant army and forward at my
opponent again.
Okay, it's it's it's it's it's like
human wave attacks.
Okay, we call this human wave attacks.
This is a this was pioneered in China,
okay? And and the Mongols just took it
and used it everywhere else.
Right? So, if you're if you're the
Mongols and you use and you're fighting
this enemy and if they're throwing these
peasants at you and you're killing them
all, but they don't know and care is
because because then like a month later
another peasant army comes at you, okay?
You quickly adopt the idea that people
are an infinite resource.
All right?
Does that make sense?
I think they were also pretty liberal
liberal's not the right word, but they
were they were pretty loose in in terms
of like who could be a Mongol or not.
Yeah. Yeah. And so it could absorb
different populations into the fighting
forces, right? So, Yeah. you could you
could you could take Chinese people in,
you could take different Turkic people
in, you could take Persians in and
That's right. Yeah. So, it sort of
depends on how cooperative you are,
basically.
That's right. Um yeah, the Mongols um
were very open society. Like like if you
had a benefit to their society and so
for example if you're a Chinese teacher
or a Chinese scholar or a Chinese
engineer,
it it or a Chinese merchant, they would
quickly assimilate you, okay?
Um and then they they would kill
everyone else.
Okay, so um they were pretty open
society.
Okay, so so does that make sense? Okay.
Great. Any more questions?
Um so so like I'm curious about you
mentioned the structure of like total
and Indo-European language structures.
Yes. And
like in different cultures have
basically the same structure, so did
people like make the structure
intentionally or was it just
coincidence? Okay, great. Okay. All
right.
So, let's talk about mythology. All
right? So, again, if you actually study
mythology,
what you recognize is
there's a structure that's very similar
across many different cultures, right?
So, if you look at Greek,
if you look at Roman,
uh Norse,
Mongolian.
Okay, I can I can go on and on and on.
Um
there's a very similar structure even
though the characters might be
different, okay? But but but it's a
mythology that celebrates violence and
individualism
as a way to remake the world, okay? It's
about strength, individualism, violence.
So, why is that the case? And it is it's
about culture, cultural values.
So,
as as I discussed in this class, culture
cultural values are the most persistent
part of who you are. Why? Because it's
part of your subconscious, okay? There's
a conscious you
and there's a subconscious.
And ultimately you are your
subconscious. And subconscious is
composed of your cultural values.
Okay? This is the essence of who you
are. So, even though the
Proto-Indo-Europeans, they were going
into different environments and they
were assimilate themselves into
different environments and they look
physically different, culturally,
subconsciously, they shared a similar
value system. And this value system will
then go on to inform the way they
perceive the world, their worldview. And
this worldview will then manifest itself
through mythology, which will eventually
become literature.
Okay?
Okay? Does that make sense? So, they
might have changed clothes,
they might have changed their hair
color, but their soul was still
Proto-Indo-European. Okay? And that same
the same is also true for language. And
that's why
um and that's why so many words
repeat themselves in different
languages, okay?
All right? Does that make sense? Okay.
Great.
Any more questions?
Okay. All right. Okay. Great. So, next
class we will go back to Europe. We will
do the Crusades, which will then take us
to the Renaissance and the Reformation
and the Scientific Revolution, okay?